mad flavor here you people think you
know it's a beautiful Tuesday night I'm
waiting to hear the snow report in
Baltimore but I'm coming baby
Thursday Friday Saturday Saint Patty's
Magoo bees but you guys I don't know
what you think uncle Joey you think like
I'm a wackadoo I'm always doing through
troops let me tell you what I'm doing
right now with my main man Zion good
piece of - not that you know television
pizza right Xavier say what's happening
baby say what's happening baby that's
right see uncle Joey is uncle Joey from
the from the bottom to the top I got you
you understand me with your for you got
a kidney hey you don't want to call me
up I'll take them I raised them like
soldiers you understand me not this is
it this is their playdate look at this
Xavier Xavier yeah that's how we do it
here you understand me every day taking
it to the hoop weather weather running
with my little dogs here cuz this is the
future these are my bodyguards you
understand what I'm seven he was gonna
taking me you you guys don't want uncle
Joey you'll be on to the next guy but
these little savages are saying uncle
Joey took me for beats it when I was
young it's tough right baby
yeah that's right that's how we do it
dawg right they yeah see I'm saying we
don't play games here I'll tell you the
back story to this some other time but I
love you guys it's not all about haha
sandy he's right
that's right no haha sandy he's here and
let's sing some trolls you ready
[Music]
there you go rockin it even with these
little little devils here I got over
here so next time you got a kid you
think he's little BOTS send them over we
get pizza we have a good time right
Xavier you know how we do it big dog
right how do we doing she don't know she
got camera shy all of a sudden I'll
check in with you guys later just in
case to let you know everything's all
right uncle Joey gotcha whether you're
for or 50 - I got your back dawg that's
how we do it but at least you'll get
pizza and some apple juice over here
uncle Joey's alright stay black
I thought I'm worth their weight